it's um it's great to have you here
today at lf-cc how did you keep it fresh
when you were playing Percival how do we
keep it fresh different routines in the
gym I would say first of all yeah just I
think a matter of keeping you know with
all the other guys and stuff and I think
you know banter and things like that is
always really important their
relationships on set and stuff just to
keep it fresh I think that's the most
important thing really miss most you
think now it's finished
the people I would say yeah the other
guys would just all come back from
Australia on a little trip over there
together and it sort of made me realize
how much I missed them merely it was
there on a day to day basis it was great
to have those guys around so I'll
certainly miss them the most yeah I want
to ask you what was the most
embarrassing experience that you had on
set when you Shuster I have no idea last
episode of the final season something in
the last oh I take what I did do yeah I
am I when I break away from the tree
yeah when I break away from the tree
when we were filming that I I strained
really hard in my head I was thinking oh
I'm gonna break these trees down am i
straight so hard I passed out for a few
seconds so there you go that was pretty
embarrassing yes yes well remembers how
did you know that people you know okay I
get it you have a punishment for dragons
on the show why do you like dragons and
how would you call a dragon I just think
a dragon is quite cool I did actually
recently do an impression of a dragon at
a QA and regretted it no regret
instantly so I won't be doing it today
in front of these people were setting
behind you so but yeah I think dragons
are quite cool and it was I always say
it was there's another character I would
play the show I was like it would be the
dragon lived to be a dragon but in the
top truck two cards I'm stronger than a
dragon in the Top Trumps cards which I
found out it's pretty good pretty happy
about that now of course as I said
Merlin's over now as a TV program but
what about Merlin the movie would you
like to be involved in that what would
you like to see happen yeah a few people
ask us this I think if that was there
happen then yeah I would I would say I
would I would be involved in that I'd
like to be involved in that whether it
happens or not is a different story but
yeah I think it would be a lot of fun to
get back together with all the guys and
make her sort of another story of I
suppose I'm not sure how it would happen
because of the way the series ended so
much or how they would make a movie
unless they brought off the back so I
don't know talking about getting back
together the guys of course you've been
filming a little while ago with Owen who
wrote directed and starred in as well
alongside you a film called cold and of
course it was kind of written for you
really as well wasn't it what was that
like yeah it was I mean I was very
grateful to Owen for for writing the
path when we talked about it in series 4
I think it was you know making a film
together and I think yeah he wrote this
amazing script and we decided to make it
so it's brilliant and it was awesome
working with Owen as a director as well
as an actor at this time so hopefully it
will be good and people will enjoy it
fingers crossed my most memorable moment
when filming for cold most memorable
moment
probably spending a lot of time in big
green waders
you know waders are yeah it's been a lot
of time in waders I was probably most
memorable thing I think I'll never have
a costume quite like that ever again but
yeah it was spending a lot of time in
the water in waders will be a memorable
thing for that film things coming up a
few black sails being one of them really
exciting people to Treasure Island tell
me more about it
so black sails is 20 years before the
events in the book Treasure Island and I
play Billy bones who's in Treasure
Island when he's 20 years younger so
it's quite cool to see like the crew
before Treasure Island captain Flynn
John Silver when it's a lot younger it's
made by the stars Network so lots of
risque stuff going on and it's kind of
what pirates should be I think you know
very rural and you know have a lot of
grit in it I think so yeah it's exciting
I'm hoping to see it very soon and I
hope it's gonna be as good as it looks
it's something that you think will be
like a recurring series
hopefully that's that's the aim I think
that's the idea of going into it they've
made some incredible sets over in Cape
Town in South Africa so all being well I
think that that will be good hopefully
the audience will respond to it and
we'll get a good good feedback from it
all
you